2019 mvp lamar jackson had his first
press conference of training camp
on wednesday and a reporter asked him
about an off season where he
ran into a jet ski and practiced with
antonio brown here's lamar jackson did
not run into a jet ski i jumped over the
jet ski fell in the water
um it was nice going to antonio brown
um i was hoping we would get him uh
still hoping a little bit
around us he was a great guy you know
you don't really see anything going on
at all you know he
pulled down the earth guy you know and
he he's passionate about this for the
football like when he was working
you can tell like this man is he going
to go like
24 7 and after workout he still wouldn't
lift it like he already prior to the
workout
he lifted um we go out there and go to
throwing routes
after that them guys when lifted some
more i'm like hey this guy is
there's no queen with him so it's like
that's the type of guy we need in our
locker room and i feel like
the locker room here is different from
any other locker room like it's
a brotherhood going on it's none of that
outside knows you know it's
strictly inside like we we worry about
each other we worry about what we have
going on
we want to win and i get to tell him he
want to win
you know it's funny to hear lamar
jackson say there's no quit with antonio
brown given that he's quit and unquit
football like four or five times
over the course of the last year but i i
still don't blame him
because the frustration comes from the
fact that the nfl has left him dangling
for all these months
as three different investigations
continue no sign of an investigation
resulting in a decision
or a suspension bob condada of the
seattle times suggested that antonio
brown could get word
this week on a suspension and he's going
to get at least one suspension because
he pleaded no contest to felony charges
arising from an altercation with the
driver of a moving truck earlier this
year chris but he's got other issues and
if the nfl comes to the conclusion
that the woman who's accused him in a
civil lawsuit of sexual assault and rape
if they conclude he did it i don't think
he ever plays against no way these are
all things that have been
hanging around for way too long it's
time for a decision to be made
so antonio brown knows how much time
he's going to miss and
so that teams like the ravens the
seahawks or whoever can make their plans
about whether or not they want to do
business with him yeah well
i mean first off you're right they need
to figure that out second
you know second thing i would go is
antonio brown hey i
need workhorse that's all i've ever
heard about him you know
raiders steelers for years i was hearing
it from the steelers i mean he gets
after it
and of course he's got great charisma
he's a cool dude i mean come on he's
freaking antonio brown
so a lot of the times yeah he's cool in
the rock locker room and all that
the problem is is when he leaves the
team or gets away from the locker room
that's when issues seem to happen or
maybe he doesn't come back on time after
he leaves the locker room whatever that
may be
so that's risky now baltimore
team that can handle it you know seattle
who we've heard hearing about
they can handle it i worry about this a
little in baltimore okay
you know he plays for the baltimore
ravens and yeah everything's cool
but when lamar jackson tucks the ball
for the 15th time of the game to run
how cool is antonio brown going to be
playing cool you know being in that
offense going
damn can we throw the ball mark ingram
lamar jackson
you know dobbins jk dobbins i mean so
that would scare me a little bit i don't
know if baltimore needs to mess with
that
at that this point with their young
weapons they have on the offensive side
of the ball
yeah and that's a great point chris
because antonio brown's going to have
one attitude that he projects to the
world as he's trying to get back in
once he's back in it all potentially
could change your priorities change your
objectives change for now his objective
is
i need to get back in the nfl i need to
get back in the nfl i need to get back
in the nfl
once he's on the ravens his objective is
i need the football in my hands i need
the football in my hands
i need the football in my hands and
remember but we've talked about this
before
there's an awkward quality here if
you're the ravens
because you've got his cousin marquise
hollywood brown on the team
and if it doesn't go well for antonio
brown
with the ravens if it all falls apart if
they have to move on from him
does he poison his cousin's mind against
that would scare me too
and i i almost feel like there's this
kind of
awkward arms length like we we want him
to feel like
we want him but we don't really want him
but we can't tell him we don't really
want him
because if we do that like kind of like
let's just hope the seahawk can somebody
else yeah somebody else do
you have to be in this awkward spot with
antonio brown because we don't want to
piss this guy off
and then he's going to do everything he
can to make his cousin not like us and
maybe not want to be part of the team
long term i think that's real
that's again it's human nature and lamar
jackson has high hopes for marquis brown
this year he's healthy
and uh we know how fast he is and we
know what he can do we saw week one
against the dolphins when they decided
to sell out against stopping the run and
they let guys run free all day long
uh hollywood brown i think for the
future of this team
far more important than the mere limited
slim prospect of antonio brown joining
the team i agreed
you know and there's some you know the
thing seattle's different to me you know
you got russell wilson there's some
older guys that been there
some maybe some more veteran leadership
i don't know you know maybe i'm off base
here but in baltimore i just feel like
it's
there might be a little more young and
impressionable to what you're saying
i mean just some of the names we've just
you know mentioned of hollywood brown
you know mark andrews a tight end it's
only year three for him of course lamar
jk dobbins coming into town uh the
receiver they got you know from uh
from the texas in the third round you
know so
those guys they could be affected for
the rest of their career by a guy like
antonio brown if he doesn't come in and
do
things exactly the right way and that
would scare me about baltimore because
you have a team that's got
incredible chemistry already and is
incredibly talented and you've really
built something
and yeah antonio brown might make you
great like
unbelievably great but he also might
disrupt your team and make it
dysfunctional
and all of a sudden you could be sitting
there going how the hell are we six and
six in week 13 here what the hell
happened to us
well you know and that that that would
scare me and that's probably why i
wouldn't mess with it if i'm baltimore
all right we're going to shift from the
afc north to the nfc north when we
return state of the franchise continues
with a team that has a wide open
quarterback competition we'll talk
chicago bears next
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports